esas protestas que ya se extienden por
11 días y que sean realizado a lo largo
de Irán algunas versiones hablan más de
80 población o donde la gente ha salido
a protestar le han quitado visibilidad a
la región del país donde tal vez se ha
llevado a cabo la mayor movilización y
tal vez también la que ha estado
mayormente aislada por el internet y por
la el nivel de seguridad que allí que es
las áreas de mayoría kurda en Irán que
están en el noroccidente del país dos
grandes provincias la de azerbaiyán
occidental y la alcurdistán de dónde era
originaria maxam mini esa joven de 22
años que estaba con su familia de visita
enteraron cuando fue capturada por la
policía de la mural y después falleció
desde el momento de su entierro se
dieron grandes protestas que se
extendieron a lo largo de las
principales ciudades del kurdistán con
una gran represión de las autoridades el
gobierno de Terán Tiene un gran temor al
levantamientos en estas áreas curvas
ellos representan el 10 100% de la
población del país si hay un gran
descontento por la manera como los ha
tratado el gobierno de Teherán a lo
largo de estas cuatro décadas de la
República islámica y grupos opositores
que operan desde el kurdistán iraquí a
los cuales las autoridades iraníes han
venido atacando desde Irán en los
últimos días pero allí en esas áreas
curvas de Irak y decir ya también han
habido protestas a favor de maxada Mini
y recordando Cómo esta mujer y todas las
mujeres del kurdistán Irán y luchan por
sus derechos